I'm very honorable to be here to talk a
little bit about retail uh business in
China and e-commerce opportunities uh
I believe majority of you don't know
my background very well especially
the company I established 20 years ago
Walmart in Chinese we call it ume so I
find very good at other advertisements
through Google search so this is a
advertisement for Walmart women yeah
uh
uh this sentence from Fortune Magazine
let's talk about Walmart you know
the
author suggests to buy a ticket to
Beijing
to
see Walmart stores instead of Walmart
because Walmart is so big name there
so uh Walmart was established 20 years
ago
uh
uh by me and then my brother he's here
as well yeah 20 years ago so right now
yeah uh Walmart has 500 stores it's one
of the biggest retailers in Northern
China
but today I'm not going to talk too much
about Walmart what I'm going to talk
about is retail in China and e-commerce
opportunity
the first thing I want to talk about is
trans retail sector seduces fast-paced
growth
um
here's a
number
you can see you know grow really rapidly
or
last year a number reached almost 4
trillion US dollar it's quite big I
checked the number uh
here in the United States
last March uh the U.S retail sales
is about
400 billion
400 billing us other last means chance
number uh only uh when trading lower
than the United States
so it's getting
closer I remember not long ago you know
the Gap is huge between China and the
United States
um
so the growth rate is quite High
and the consumption upgrade is mainly
powered by the large portion of middle
income households you can see all the
numbers here
you know back to
you know
the number
was very very low
but now it's quite High
54 Millions let's talk about
one family has three to four people
the number is quite big
and also it's growing very rapidly
so this is the reason why the retail
business grows so fast
additionally more spending on food
will be another important growth driver
for the retail sector
you see here you know
China
is due
belong to this group break
Brazil Russia
China turkey and South Africa
uh
the GDP per capita is not very high and
the
the people suspending on food
still has a very big room to grow here
is the United States
foreign
Germany so
if China
Moon
from here
to this place
you know Chinese retail business
sales will be even bigger and larger
most spending on food will be another
important growth driver for retail
sector
you see China is here a little bit
higher than India
Spain is here
you know
so there's big room
to grow
here's a table to describe retailers in
the United States we use because you
know this table
is translated from Chinese
uh definitely the data
comes from the United States statistics
but
we use this table to discuss challenge
retail situation in the United States
there are 27 retailers
have annual sales
of over
100 billion RMB is about
16 billion US dollar
but in China
right now only while two retailers sales
is over 100 billion RMB but however
China's
uh
economy is about six percent big of the
United States
so that means a chance retail industry
is very fragmented
you know we have many many small and
media sized
uh retailers but we
are lack of big retailers like Walmart
you know warmer sales is about
500 billion US dollar worldwide yeah
you mean in the United States is 300
billion U.S dollars
so this table tells us
there's really big room for Chinese
retail industry to be consolidated
now I'm going to talk about the
supermarket and Hypermarket uh
and I was asked by Richard so what's the
difference between supermarket and the
Hypermarket
no big difference you know
just the bigger and probably carry more
merchandise
um
Hypermarket is a definition from Europe
uh in the United States people talk
about Walmart Supercenter
in a Walmart Supercenter it's very
similar to the concept of Hypermarket
that means there's big fresh Department
Grocery
and hot Goods
uh supermarkets has
fresh Department grocery some of hot
Goods yeah
yeah so we put
supermarkets and hypermarkets together
as a group
now
you can find some
numbers here
you know talk about hyper marketing
supermarkets per
10 000 Urban population
Canada is a night
point zero nine China only
2.26 in this even lower in this even
lower
talk about selling area
per capita you know
China
is still quite low compared with the
Canada and the United States
this is another evidence supermarkets
and hypermarkets
has big room to develop in China
you know I I have mentioned that
supermarket and Hyper Market industry in
China is very fragmented thus
you know
you will see
a big consolidation in this industry in
next three to five years
um
that means you can find a supermarket
chain with the 100
battling R B Sales
200 billion RMB sales even 500 billion
RMB sales as the market is huge and
1.3 billion people live there
many of them
are becoming middle income
uh personnels
question
in the color
uh
in fact no big difference I think you
know I discussed with Richard some
some
problems caused you know my version you
know I made in China cannot exactly
reflect here yeah
sure
yes exactly you see Walmart here we are
very strong in Beijing and the nearby
area in fact we are big retailer in
Beijing we have a 25 to 30 percent
market share in fast moving
consumer goods
in learning Province you say you know
it's called dashang
in Shandong Province it's Li
chunsu province is yeah
very fragmented
here is
I noticed some people may come from
China you may know better yeah
do you mind questions during the talk
yeah sure yeah go ahead yeah oh sorry I
haven't noticed
I'm not you know yeah yeah
it's kind of a dumb fat of mine actually
you know okay
is making big progress in past
five years yeah yeah so what's the
reason behind the China Market is really
kind of programmatic so there is kind of
carrying things investment or kind of
you know it's hard to manage the
national wife supply chain yeah this is
a really good question but the reason is
supermarket
is quite new to China
uh when I started my business in Beijing
Back to December
1994. in fact I opened the first
supermarket in Beijing even in Beijing
at that time you know
the one here
you know didn't
involved in this business yet yeah he's
younger and he's much younger than me
yeah so and this is the one reason
another is what you said or supply chain
is very fragmented you know and very
localized
uh not long ago China does not have
efficient
Expressway system you know China just
finish
building the Ephesians suppression you
know system highway system so the
consolidation will happen in next three
to five years
yeah
sure sure
the United States Walmart
on that map would it be Associated more
with just Beijing and Shanghai or what
where would it be
very good question you know Walmart
is very different from local players
right you know Walmart has a lot of
money has all techniques uh have
experience so when they enter China
they just almost go to Every provinces
so uh they are not very specifically
strong at
a specific Province this is why you know
if you talk about learning province is
not the biggest if you talk about the
Shannon province is not the biggest it's
the reason but overall Walmart has
I guess you know not official number
Walmart doesn't publish that number one
ourselves in China is about a 40 billion
RMB yeah Walmart has
Super Center
has Sam's Club
and some community stores
yeah that's true yeah they close down
yeah and some stores uh do not perform
well so they decide to close the store
think
compare with the United States
you know your judgment is true but
compare Walmart's performance in India
in the warmer China is very successful
uh
behind what behind the China you know
Walmart is doing better
yeah
but compared to the local Planet uh
is back to the richest party you know
Richard always talk about
entrepreneurship you know this is maybe
the difference you know for big
International Company when they come to
China they try to call it the business
model they were successful
in his Home Market
uh for local people like a better life
people here one thing you know his
entrepreneur he started the business he
tried to innovate she tried to meet
local customers meet very very carefully
so maybe this is the difference
can we get through the the the
presentation maybe we can come back to
this point because I think there's some
interesting things okay so I know this
girl maybe I take his her question yeah
one point to raise it because it's kind
of related to your question could you
talk a little bit more about Archie
martyr who is also at Taiwan and trying
to
um but they seem to be localizing quite
well and so would you do a little
comparison on that point yeah okay yeah
uh our team
is uh very successful in China
um you know when you say a financial
data in fact it's two companies combined
together
ultimate plus ocean from
France
uh RT Mart is very localized because RT
is operated by Taiwanese
you know they are very very Chinese and
you know they are kind of entrepreneurs
especially Peter Huang you know I know
him personally
the CEO of T-Mart yeah so this reason
why art he is very successful yeah
things
uh okay
right now e-commerce is very very hard
topic so I cannot avoid to talk about
that in the research suggest me you know
it's better touches issue
you know
I think everybody know some
facts
China's e-commerce Market
is really big and fast growing even
compared with the United States the
growth rate is high you know people even
talk about the total sales of e-commerce
in China it's bigger than the United
States
I think the reason behind that is
uh
China's traditional retail
business is so weak
that e-commerce
has great opportunity
to take the advantage
you know
in China
all top 10
e-commerce websites
a new companies now like in the United
States maybe you can see Amazon you can
say ebays however
Walmart
staple you know
uh office smart
they are very strong you can you know
Macy not strong yeah so maybe eight of
the top ten
websites are traditional retailers but
in China all of them are news uh
so
there are some dators I I don't want to
elaborate too much so what's the
percentage of b2c what's representable C
to say maybe some
a good story you have heard already like
Jack ma he speaks here
two three years ago I talk about his
dream right now his dream just
becomes true yeah and I read the article
discuss the perspect of uh alibaba's IPO
that article even predict the market cap
for Alibaba could be
240 billion US dollars
you know this is a really big even
bigger than Amazon closer to
Google
check them out does have very strong
financial data to support you know his
market cap you know last year his
company's profit was over
uh 3.5 billion US dollar you know for
and you know e-commerce company is
really good and also the growth rate is
quite High you know groceries quite High
still 50 60 percent
you know so
um in addition to
uh uh Jackman's story I think the most
successful
uh e-commerce company is where I peace
you know
the market cap right now is 10 billion
US dollar the good stories all of them
uh is listed and will be listed in the
United States
foreign
data
comparison between China and the United
States
here is
some analysis about
why China's
online shopping kangaroo so fast as I
mentioned
you know fragmented retail industry
in efficient traditional China
High logistical cost this number is
very very important you know logistical
costs are account for 18 chance GDP
uh
this is an interesting
argument
you know
in the United States every
e-commerce players
try to make money
but in China
a story is different
majority of
e-commerce companies lose money
because
so many Venture capitalists
invest on them they try to grab market
share first
um this is a number
you know build installer
have been
put in in this industry yeah
and also
no taxation is chart on sales conducted
by small and media online retailers
this is another you know point for
your Commerce developer
employees yeah basically China
does not proton tax on e-commerce
business so this is really good for them
yeah so
and even for you know in the US for
PayPal
you have to under the regulation for
financial
institutes but in China you know for
online you know payment system
you still have kind of
freedom
to just do it yeah
yeah
here are some data about
uh
uh the market shares you know
that's the reason why
makes so much money yeah the market
share is really really big for
Alibaba
uh
who
are hurt most
like e-commerce
specialty stores
you know
so you can see here for Home Appliance
and the next
sufferer is departing the stores
supermarket and Hypermarket
doing
quite well to protect
their market share from e-commerce
attacked the reasons for French and
other food products you know e-commerce
cannot really perform well can really
make some money
yeah
so in the future
for the supermarket the Hypermarket
sector
what we can do is
emphasize on fresh food effective cost
control
uh guarantee the quality
and also try to do
o2o
yeah
so I further explained
fresh food is the best way to find off
online shopping
oh
now I'm going to talk about Walmart a
little bit the company is established
in 1994
it is the first supermarket in Beijing
um
you know
the first year so the sales exceeded
uh 100 Milli RMB
you know initially
I start another company
it's a technology company
I try to sell
Point of Sales and
at that time it's not Erp called Miss
management information system to
existing retailers but nobody really
think my software and my posts are
useful so I decided to start showcase
store this is a Walmart coming from but
the first Year's business
went so well so the sales was over 100
million RMB and the show a little bit of
profit and also very strong cash flow
very strong cash flow so you know I
decided to open more stores this is how
a Walmart
comes from
uh the company went to
public in Hong Kong at 2003
uh
we began to do some
acquisition modern localization
uh
and the
some important investors
I think we also should mention the World
Bank is our initial invest and also
Capital group do you come from World
Bank
oh really you know this story right
I see yeah yes yeah yeah and they at
that time I've seen made the decision
very very quickly
last one month yeah and also I've seen
it ten times you must have seen some
yeah yeah earning from
oh there's some you know the Lord
say Walmart his first growing company
oh there are some Financial dators
I think basically that's all I want to
talk today Richard said that it's better
for me talk to
45 minutes I think
what's up let's move into q a because
I've got all kinds of questions that
your presentation raises for me at least
first of all thanks very much yeah
so when we talk about entrepreneurship
one of the things that you usually get
is you get a difference between the
mom-and-pop store kind of
Entrepreneurship and then the real
growth entrepreneurship that happens in
technology areas how did Wu Mart keep
from being just a nice
one store
business and what kept you growing how
to why why did wilmart not just become
the mom-and-pop store yeah you know
Richard the the reason behind that is
you know my major is computer science
okay you know without a computer system
you really cannot have more stores yeah
I can give you very simple
example or
let's say we sell Coca-Cola and Pepsi
um both of the both of both of them
maybe one yuan in China
you know if you sell One Coca-Cola
then
one Pepsi
so in fact your inventory should be
reduced
you know One Coca-Cola one Pepsi however
when custom pay
they only pay two yards
so if you re-register
you know you
sell two Coca-Cola that means your
inventory
will be in trouble
so you said well you know I need
to replenish two Coca-Cola but in fact
you only sell one
then you have too many Coca-Cola's there
but you will
you know be lack of Pepsis
so this is the computers so you simplify
that back in 1994 you had a point of
sale system yeah I guess you were using
that to kind of do inventory management
then right yeah okay so tell us a little
bit about what you think about big data
analytics and retailing
yeah
you know
people began to talk about Big Data
nowadays but in fact for retailers you
know we began to do that a long time ago
because we really have a lot of food
data on
for example you know we have about
10 million members how many members
you know we register with us we have
their mobile phone number and
ID is it a system that we would be
familiar with here where you get points
or you get a discount if you're a member
that kind of thing yeah okay you know
yeah that we have the data
how much they purchase from Walmart
and what kind of things yeah they bought
even you know
uh what they return right you know this
is very important for us and we can
analyze
there
Behavior then to predict
their income and to predict what
they will buy in the future yeah yeah
okay this is what we are doing yeah so
is that why your very first slide so if
you want to see the Walmart of the
future go look at rumart now is that
what he was thinking about or what do
you think yeah on his mind you know uh I
think that
uh statement
it's not very true you know Walmart is
the leader of the traditional retail
business and certainly have a large I.T
that is doing very very well you know
500 billion US dollar sales uh I use
that words just for
Fortune Magazine has some credits so I
use it but Frankly Speaking you know
Walmart to the Pioneer for many things
you know Walmart use the computer system
very very well you know starting from
some water you know warm at create many
retail formats you know Walmart is a
real
innovators yeah okay yeah you know I
come here to learn something from
Walmart okay so let me give up the floor
for a minute and let other people ask
questions
into the science and I've heard stories
from years ago when Walmart is one of
the first retail in China to implemented
European life
initially we use our own system and yeah
later we use sap stories you know one of
my friends
fly to Beijing to you know negotiable I
want to introduce a Oracle EDS to manage
your Erp and ASAP you know it's kind of
fun again so it's kind of a yeah about
the story yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's a nice story but uh a
little bit different you know
uh I fly here I did the meat like right
listen at his headquarter you know but
finally you know we decided to select
sap yeah this is the story
because you're kind of a computer
science degree yeah what is difference
yeah the reason is uh
ICP system is more stable we want a
stable system and the woman has
three formats you know we think as if he
can help us better another reason is
Oracle
didn't have retail
business yet at that time they just
acquired a new company you know we think
the integration will take some time yeah
eggs yeah
yeah please
back to your math of the retail shop the
province
is not covered and adaptive province has
the most capable uh Merchants all over
the world and how come there's no
supermarket in that problem oh yeah
let's learn to the question you know
uh into the young province
there are several
big retailers
uh number one is
very big and also our you know
performance in Jordan is quite good
especially in Northern Georgian province
in Hangzhou and the nearby areas and
there's a very big retailers in Nimble
area
and Walmart has many stores
uh in Georgian Province you know we do
not put some name there it's suggests
because uh still not a
a dominant company there yeah
are are you aware of changes in sight
daily lifestyle patterns as a result of
the increase in the supermarket sector
because it used to be people in Asia
would buy the day's food and a little
bit of things ahead but not a whole lot
not not like here in the U.S where you
buy a week's worth of food at once
sometimes yeah yeah Richard it's a
really good question you know
retail business for last 20 years
the people's living Style
buying Titans
have changed tremendously you know when
we opened the first supermarket in
Beijing at that time majority of
Beijing residents
purchase
their
pork the vegetable almost everything
from White Market
you know gradually they are changing
right now I think in Beijing in big
cities Beijing Shanghai
about seven to eighty percent residents
bye
porks vegetable fruits from Supermarket
from the supermarket you know they care
the safety issues morning yeah I was
going to ask about that if you buy
something from Big shin
regardless Walmart or Walmart if
something happened
you know you can really find the right
the guy yeah who is responsible for that
if you buy something from White Market
that's right go ahead back in the back
yeah in the United States when Walmart
opens a store in a really a small town
or any town it's really one of the
things that happens is a lot of the
smaller stores go out of business
uh do you see that happening in China
too on this new store
uh
impact I don't think
this is a big problem for China yet you
know because as I mentioned China's
retail Market is still very fragmented
although you know chance GDP is 60
percent of the United States but
or if you talk about
top 100 retailers market share of retail
business
in the United States
you know the number could be 60 70 but
in China
maybe only 10 percent
15 I show that to data in this slide but
I didn't elaborate
you know we study that this is the
reason why the warmer effect does not
happen in China yet
yeah yeah
my question I'd like to know your
your thoughts about
um
e-commerce actually be more of uh
m-commerce it's more about the today's
disruptions which is you know um
m-commerce everybody's got smartphones
and the growth of the phones and
smartphones in China and then more
specifically on top of that gamified
loyalty programs and their role on how
to behaviorally you know direct the
consumers
um into your into your locations
I think
this
could be very important you know for
the competition in the future
uh
in the event I mentioned for
retailers
you know in China the fresh department
is very strong to find out e-commerce
but I believe I believe uh
we have to use
you know mobile
internet
to attract customers to communicate with
the customers to manage our
member system this is very important I
just read the report civil spent one
hour
on his mobile phone every day
so many people
just depends on mobile phone to get
their information so no choice
you know for us you know we have to go
through
you know mobile internet
is very concentrated right now in China
and you said that tons of people would
pour lots of money for this segment is
it is this still is there still
opportunity for entrepreneurship in that
space or do you think it's really
saturated and overcrowded and you know
there's
I mean there's a Gmail there's Bank code
there's tons of other e-commerce
Specialties are there still space yeah
there are a lot of opportunities great
opportunities like a channel you know
came back to China not long ago in the
channel is the founder of Gmail you know
just
it's a ready to be public in New York
Stock Exchange you know the market cap
could be three billion for billion US
dollar this guy still own 40 of the
company we're a smart guy he graduated
from a graduate school you know of
business GSP yeah uh you know but pay
attention
to the real opportunity
you know I think
the first round e-commerce award you
know just have a website in uh you went
to capitalists put the town's money
into a company that story over but you
have to select the opportunity like
Jimmy
a channel just grab one of the best
options you know
in China for cosmetic products usually
the makama markup is huge
a hundred percent
150 percent but you know for one bottle
beauty products
it can can cause maybe 100 and 200 500
yen so the delivery cost is very low
and also the profit margin could be very
high
this is why you know Channel
becomes so successful he selects the
right niche
so if you don't mind I want to follow
through a little bit on the e-commerce
thing yeah so with regard to the sort of
Supermarket segment in the U.S back
before the.com crash was WebEx yeah and
WebEx was an online only Supermarket
yeah
excuse me what am I saying oops sorry
about that web van yeah and okay so web
ban over expanded yeah and they went
down yeah and uh then you know I think
Safeway actually bought the rights to
their system and there were a few kind
of brick and mortar supermarkets that
were doing kind of deliveries you know
based on electronic Commerce orders but
it never really went anywhere it was
almost like the car company selling
electric cars you sort of thought they
didn't really care about it
do you see anything is is China really
moving for
in the supermarket segment to really
become more aggressive and fulfilling
e-commerce orders no okay yeah uh the
reason
for web OS yeah failure is
for fresh things yeah it's not easy
to perform
you know daily delivery you know this is
true this is a really hard thing but for
beauty products it's very easy yeah yeah
you know for 100
dollar you know beauty products I can
send to you you charge me thank you on
you know one half dollar it's okay yeah
yeah but uh for you know one piece of a
pork I deliver to you you know
they only worth 50 runs then and the
delivery cost was 250 euro yeah right is
it too big it's too big yeah okay so
this is the usually definitely for cocoa
color you know
big box are the are the supermarkets
five dollar you know ten dollars so but
I charge you two dollars delivery fee
you think it's too much
are the supermarkets trying to increase
the number of
items they hold increase the number of
skus to sort of match more of the
Walmart model or
do you think that's going to happen in
China no I don't think so I think
uh
Chinese supermarkets should
focus on
selecting best merchandise mix
for their customers rather you know have
too many red and everything yeah yeah
that's cute okay yeah okay go ahead you
had a question
yeah so I was wondering you're obviously
a relatively mature company who has a
fantastic growth at this point do you
find that you're going to be growing
organically by building your own stores
whereas the concept of acquiring other
competitors
organic growth and
uh consolidation of the industry
it's very very attractive so much of
your competition because you can just
really grow and deliver for investors
very quickly so you actually see it as
doing both
uh yeah uh I think the you know if I
understand your question you know we try
to do both things organic growth is very
important same store growth and uh open
new stores however the consolidation is
very very important at this stage
you know the market is so fragmented
that the consolidation is seriously
needed
works
for example if the woman or better life
during whatever acquire a company
whether or not you can really improve
the business whether or not you can
really make the supply chain
most successful yeah and more efficient
did anyone ever try to acquire rumor
yeah some people are talking about that
yeah in the past have you turned down
people
uh yes okay yeah yes you would went
public on the Hong Kong exchange right
in 2012 2013. uh HKS yeah
2003 2003 yeah okay okay 10 years ago
yeah okay yeah
um I think we are
planning something yeah
uh we may focus on o2o however right now
I believe as I mentioned uh we will use
mobile e-commerce
to enhance our communication with
customers with members this is the first
not no sale yet yeah we have to be very
very careful you know make sure
our way is correct you know we are not a
new company we have
many shareholders we have to be
responsible for them
go ahead
continue do we want to talk about your
most Market strategy meaning it's a
market positioning against another
competitors and what kind of operation
technical plans to support this strategy
uh technical well it also position
high-end versus medium what kind of
Market positioning yeah to be
distinctive from competitors I think
Walmart's currently
focus on
you know middle income household yeah uh
you know
if we want to
serve hand customers
we may have a new format yeah yeah
so this is the right you know right now
this is the strategy yeah
so I want to ask you a question about
what things felt like in 1994 when you
started Walmart here you were with a
prestigious background you know working
for the state Council then getting a PhD
from the Chinese Academy of Sciences
coming here uh working with you know
very prestigious institutions in China
um
what happened what was it that made you
absolutely convinced that you wanted to
be an entrepreneur yeah uh this is a you
know
uh really uh good question uh
I came to the United States the first
time is back to 1990. you know I was a
well received by a professor here named
Roberta Larson Richard knew him very
well
and I think that trip
was very important to my life
you know I really realized
uh
uh entrepreneurship is very very
important you know back to 1990 early
1990 you know in China everything
belong to government
it's very different from today
uh so I noticed here the market
play
the major role
in everything
your economy even in
especially if you're around thought
about academic award so I I think while
it's better
to live differently I went back to China
in 1993
I started my own business you know Dr
Larson
his General partner for Woodside fund I
went to the capital
he supported me yeah and
you know
another
Big Driver for me to start business is
China's Paramount leader thank you made
a very famous trip to Southern China you
may hear that you know you know he
restarted China's economic reform under
open door policy
so 19 you know he made that too in early
1992 so in 1993 the
the policy environment is very different
you know the central government began to
encourage people to start their private
businesses this is a background yeah did
you find that there was a social side to
being an entrepreneur though especially
you know this was you were early
yeah early for China
yeah you know
uh we have I think I think has a word uh
he talked about him
means you have to try you know before
you really do something yeah so uh we
have some
friends you know really begin
uh doing business almost simultaneously
all those people are called the
uh 1992 entrepreneurs to our 1992
entrepreneurs you know they uh
uh come from uh government
branches from
you know academic organizations you know
they began to do many of them right now
are very very successful some people
might argue that
being a government employee is not
necessarily the right background to
become an entrepreneur
yes what kind of things do you think
were the hardest lessons
I don't think garments
officials have bigger and advantage to
become entrepreneurs you know if you
want to start something if you want to
create something you have to you know
you have to suffer
a lot of but you know
cultures you know from all different
aspects
you know in China government officials
do not have this kind of experience you
know they say there are many people
come to them try to get the kind of
approach yeah so I don't think that's
important for people to be successful in
business area okay you don't human
pleasure yeah thank you very much it was
an amazing overview of retail in China
so when I turn things around for a
moment because you're talking about
there's clearly huge opportunity in
China still for growth in retail in the
supermarket yet in the United States a
lot of retailers are trying to reinvent
themselves reinvent retail to make it
more exciting more interesting trying to
use technology trying to use pop-up
stores to try things before you put a
product in a large-scale uh launch in
many stores so even though it may not be
your first priority do you do some r d
or thinking about what might retail look
like in China in five and ten years and
made the Chinese consumer hunger for
some of the experiences that retailers
are trying to create here yeah
uh
I think you know
China has learned a lot
from the United States
for myself you know I saw supermarket in
the United States
you know
uh some Chinese supermarket here
uh Safeway and Lucky stores although
Lancaster may not exist today Walmart
you know Press Club
right now it's called Costco
and I believe China will continue to
learn a lot from the United States for
example
we are expecting some
Mac retailers there you know this is
something happened in the United States
however uh
we have more new challenges today
for example
mobile internet this is a really new
thing you know you have to consider
all those new challenges you know you
have to consider e-commerce
you know slow
in today China's Market
so uh we will be very careful you know
in this aspect you know mobile internet
is new to us and it's new to China so we
Face the new challenge
simultaneously we do not have you know
much to copy from the United States
it doesn't like us when I open
Supermarket you know although at that
time you know the the situation
you know uh is really not good for us to
do some new things uh we cannot buy
a shelf you know I have to
make
the shelves ourselves based on my memory
okay the Shelf should be this way you
know we make it
in the spot yeah so
today you know the challenge
you know it's same to us and China so we
have to you know I know it ourselves
on
additionally I think uh
China's retailers
you know have better opportunities then
yeah the retailers in the United States
because the market is ready the people's
income still increased quite rapidly you
know seven percent eight percent GDP
growth
for Chinese they think it's a very slow
but compared with other nations still
quite fast yeah I hope that answers your
questions so actually I want to turn
this around yeah you were being very
humble in saying that China still has a
lot to learn from the United States what
do you think in retail industries does
the U.S have things to learn from China
um
well I think
for
acquiring new customers
I think some Chinese retailers
I mean for e-commerce operators yeah
they are very aggressive you know in
this aspect
the Chinese
operators
probably
give U.S operators
this gentleman mentioned you know they
just give us the buildings very fast
it's three four years the market cap is
for billing you know for Via Keys now
it's 10 billion just three four years
yeah so they became the the good part is
they are profitable now
oh
uh back to 1994
I think a supermarket
is uh
Banker to show
our point of sale and management
information system
yeah you know
um
for supermarkets
you have to select merchandise by
yourself
you have to have your own inventory
in China for departmental stores even
for homeless appliance stores usually
they let wonders
control their own inventory
you know they just take her
Commission from Wonder
so that's the reason why we started from
supermarket and uh luckily I think this
is a very right decision yes
um interesting story thanks for sharing
it with us
um so with the U.S uh brands are so
important yeah and you know our Walmart
our Target and our grocery stores
and that also reflects
um like the agric bag business we have
so like a lot of different food makers
and Farmers
um is this a challenge in China are you
working with very large agricultural
companies or small ones how does that
all work how's that challenge for you
yeah initially we deal with many many
different companies in the many many
suppliers
producers but gradually you know
Wayne say
s
have been changed you are using more and
more big barriers to deal with you for
example for beauty products
the PNG a Unilever
are crappy in Chinese market
uh even for agricultural products
usually we deal with
farmers you know individually
but now
you can see uh the
self-organized company or maybe
Cooperative deal with deal with you and
we begin to purchase our agricultural
products from
you know Countryside
directly
you know without
middleman's involving yeah
this is what we are doing now yeah so I
saw your hand next yeah go ahead thank
you what were some of the important
decisions you made in your early days to
contribute to the your success you must
make some critical decisions go
therefore right you made the right call
and then you have your Us store starting
booming you through so many stores
maybe the the first important decision
is to
work for herself yeah to be entrepreneur
yeah you know when I started the
business uh initially
uh I paid myself 800 Yen per month
you know it's at that time you know a 10
year and you call one US dollar that
means I paid myself
you know less than 100 dollars yeah as
Richard mentioned you know I have a kind
of prestigious position but now I meet
very little money you have to sacrifice
somehow you have to take the risk
and I think
the decision
of entering little business is a
good decision uh because when you start
a business uh
the capital
is a big issue for you
um
when I started
my retail business you know initial kept
requirement
was very very low only I remember for
the first store I only invest three
million RMB but the cells you know
was uh 100 million annually so this is a
very good start and also I have probably
you know
uh 10 to 15 many RMB
possible cash flow so this is very
important
for me to open more stores
maybe this is something I can share with
you yeah
so
so go ahead
issue yes it's so a really popular Trend
now is in organic food eating healthy
and food safety and all that stuff and
it's remarkable what you have to think
if understood it right well you just
stated that you work directly with
Farmers I've lived briefly in Portland
Oregon and I'm kind of my brother's work
with Organic you know food companies and
stuff so it's kind of intriguing to uh
your position then
in terms of helping the Chinese people
eat you know healthy and
safe food so is that is that a preserve
any kind of specific marketing efforts
you're doing around that yeah yeah I
think
you know your party is very very
important
you know due to
a serious illusion in middle class in
China especially for wealthy Chinese uh
pay a lot of attention
to for the safety and this is the reason
s are important products in our stores
have been very very easy sales increase
very rapidly you know for some store
sales 20 30 yeah
um
last week
you know we got a chance with Governor
Jerry Brown you know uh he had lunch
with us with a small group of Chinese
entrepreneur
a try to promote California
agricultural products in China and
especially you know ask me you know what
his plan you know
we think
this is
very important
and U.S products will have respectable
against us will have a very very good
Market
time
you know we say that
150 million really income household
a potential buyers of the U.S organic
products
my question relates to entrepreneurship
and development and yeah
um moving startups in China I mean
you've gone through you know your
experience in the retail sector what do
you see as the main
impediments and challenges that young
entrepreneurs face in in China today
yeah today yeah okay so your definition
is very important in today's environment
is very different from 20 years ago
I think
you know right now the environment is
much better
the legal system is better and also you
can have
financial support from Winter capitalist
and local governments
on many Chinese local governments open
uh special
uh region for young entrepreneurs to
start their business especially for some
oversee Chinese students
if they have a good business plan if
they come back to China they can get
maybe half a million or a million RMB to
try their ideas
and I put a part of those kind of
investment could be a long not an
initial capital
so basically the situation is much
better it's the reason why you know like
uh
would you have any special
recommendations to young people
interested in starting companies in
China now
yeah why I think
you have to have
uh the determination you know if you
want to
do business
in China
not only in China even in the United
States you know you have to be ready you
know there are a lot of challenges
on the
in addition to that
you have to have
a very clear idea what you really want
to do yeah yeah
um definitely you can try many times you
can be a Serial
entrepreneurs but I think
you know uh
it's better for you to really have a
concrete
and real
good idea before you begin to do
something yeah no sorry follow-up
question on that very quickly do you see
it some differences between the
ecosystem that exists here in the valley
to support entrepreneurs and say the
ecosystem in the Beijing area on the
Shanghai area you see things well you
know compare with the
Silicon Valley
I have to say
here is the best
you know either Beijing or Shanghai here
that doesn't exist there
there are a lot of things
you know for example in Palo Alto High
School there is a
Harley entrepreneur Club
that club has 89 registered members and
one of the member even made his two
millions
when he is a high school student
so this is really different you know
uh I think
here
is a
you know the culturally innovative
place this is you know really different
the first thing the second thing
uh
people here enjoy
much more freedom yeah so this is how
for people to start something new
to be creative
and
talk about
the financial support and legal support
although leading in Shanghai have been
improved tremendously
but
here is the best yeah no doubt that's
the reason why Facebook here you know
Google here you know continuing